how old are you I'm 20 you got [ __ ]  time it's a it's a balance of regret and  patience look you can go hard on for  three years do nothing right wake up and  be young as [ __ ] you should really go to  a retirement home one day and volunteer  and just talk to them it will make you  wanna do [ __ ] every minute in your life  because when you see regret in a man's  eyes it's [ __ ] painful because you  have can't do [ __ ] about it when you're  90 and you're not mobile and you're  tired and it's over you can't do it you  can't do it you can't build that company  you wanted you can't spend that time  with your kid you it's regret and it  [ __ ] drives the [ __ ] out of me times  are for me great I'm on my mom credit  Golf for me tears down a job for me  unless you know these demons draw for me  she's no evil no father